hi Cory I'm bill Brody I'm the president
of the Johns Hopkins University in
Baltimore Maryland in the United States
and I want to thank you for your very
moving video showing the pictures of
want and destruction from war and
various forms of internal conflict I
think the one thing that I would like to
convince our leaders of around the world
is to learn the power of nonviolent
resistance like Martin Luther King in
the United States did so profoundly or
Mahatma Gandhi in India if we could
convince our leaders that whenever they
use force there's countervailing force
and want and destruction of innocent
civilians and bystanders that the war is
never the way to go and we need to push
more towards peaceful resistance thank
you so much for your video and good luck
and let's work together on this